very intimate I believe all the BuzzFeed
videos I've done I've never brought you
guys do shower
I was sitting at the bar the other day
and this girl was telling me that she
was very stressed out so she had an
orange in the shower which completely
took me by surprise and that was very
intrigued by it and apparently last year
people were doing this there's a lot of
articles talking about this so I figured
why don't we actually try it
I've never heard of this but I'm very
excited to do it because I love or just
I love citrus I also love hot showers
I've done a shower tea which is very
nice just having a nice warm tea in the
shower I've also taken like eucalyptus
essential oil and just dropped it in my
shower and that is actually very
pleasant I definitely think this is
going to be weird because I just like to
go in with my shower really quick do my
thing and leave especially because I'll
be eating an orange which I don't like
to eat anyways I'll buy into any like
self-care [ __ ] so I'm like a basic
ass white girl but like what is this
supposed to do ideally first thing in
the morning grab the orange from the
fridge so it has to be cold get the hot
shower ready which is no problem with
the water running over you begin to peel
the orange with your hand do not worry
about the juices getting on you be messy
actually oh let's do this question mark
I'm grabbing my cold orange from the
fridge I'm getting this shower nice and
warm okay
doing it back about feeling something
and throwing down instantly much better
than care and my shop already know great
good I know I'm supposed to peel the
orange but my other hand was holding the
phone psychic Africa village back in
Palma
[Music]
the contrast of the orange and the
shower is completely unchanged
I feel neither sexy or relaxed I feel
full I thought it was a pretty cool
activity however I wouldn't do that
often because it felt like a waste of
water and then I had to clean up the
orange peels and that sort of thing
other than that I thought it was pretty
cool and that did find it to be very
relaxing actually really enjoyed having
that citrus smell while I was peeling
the orange in the shower it was very
soothing very relaxing to have that
smell feels like you're eating an orange
in a shower
there wasn't anything transcendent about
that for me it's kind of cool to have
something like cold and a hot shower I
guess but like that's pretty minor I
like it and I would try it again I'm
actually very curious to try it again
but with another fruit that I like since
I am NOT crazy about oranges I think I
like this a lot better while I'm eating
a strawberry or raspberry
[Music]